I mean honestly Tom was a
Beast he he came in with a fire and that
fire helped him tremendously
um he
he definitely he definitely has his
corks but we all do
um what's his Quirk uh Tom sorry I'm I'm
exposing you here
I think he's been exposed but yeah and
I'm not mad about sharing this because
we all got in trouble for it he we had a
very
crappy bathrooms on Special Forces you
are you you do not cut cameras at
midnight and go to a hotel you are
literally in their world and you don't
see producers you don't see directors
like it is the 4ds and that is it so our
bathroom situation was janky and you had
to take a buddy and you had to run and
it was a whole thing and well found out
the DS comes in our accommodations and
they're like somebody pissed in a corner
and didn't feel like going to the
bathroom in the middle of the night and
we all got in trouble for it and it
turned out to be Tom and he just like
whipped it out and pissed in a corner
and like listen I he didn't know like
the rules were like that strict at the
time he wasn't potty trained he wasn't
potty trained yet no um but no I I have
from from forces I have good memories
with Tom I have strong numbers of Tom so
far they're great yeah pissed in the
corner and it fits in a corner and
everybody got in trouble did he admit
that he pissed in the corner he did come
on because when he gets caught we're
like who did he say that he thought that
his relationship with the toilet was
over so that he was okay with pissing in
the corner it was just like I just
thought it'd be faster like I didn't
feel like I had to go all the way over
there
um and and in hindsight it does it it
doesn't matter but at the time we're
like Tom like come on
um did he talk about the show at all and
what had happened he he did a little bit
um once we all got to kind of know each
other a little bit better we this is
this is why Nick and uh Tyler and I got
super close because you have to rely on
each other because you don't speak to
your family you don't speak to your
friends you are away and you are in the
most stressful situation that you can be
and so like
uh like that's that's why they became
like instant family to me
um and yeah they always say if you've
got to trust one person it should be a
Sandoval that's what
back here in America that's what
everybody was saying it should
absolutely be a Sandoval um and so he
Tom would you know bring things up to us
he would confess things to us and and he
would talk about things
and there was days two where he would
get frustrated about things and
frustrated about the world and what they
think of him and
honestly I think it was kind of
refreshing for him to hear that somebody
didn't know what was going on I won't
ever forget it there was this car ride
or maybe we were in our dry room and he
was ranting and I was like Tom it's like
I gotta be honest with you I have no
clue who you're talking about I was like
I know I know there's an Ariana and I
know there's a Raquel but I don't know
which one you were with and which one
you're with now and I don't I don't
care either you know like I
I think you
are entertaining to the world and I
think I think unfortunately you are
I didn't tell him this and I and I I
would tell him this now and so I don't
think I would ever say anything that I
wouldn't say to somebody straight up but
the world loves to hate him and it's
it's similar to The Miz on WWE he plays
the villain The Miz is probably one of
the nicest men I know he is incredible
dad incredible friend
um and yeah it's like that's that's his
whole gig in the WWE is people like to
boo him and Tom unfortunately it's just
it's like WWE he is actually an amazing
boyfriend who will just
F her best friend for the show yeah it's
all for the show everything he's amazing
but the difference is the Wiz is playing
a character he's like or what it is what
Tom took in the corner of that room The
Miz knows what he's doing and that he's
the villain and he's okay with that and
that's his gig I think like leading up
to this point Tom
wanted to be seen as not the villain
yeah and I think now also remember
we don't know everything you know we
don't know everything that went on
behind closed I I've heard there's still
stuff coming out about them and I heard
that it was all fine and then I heard
that it was now there's another tornado
happening and I also think
a scandal for some is addicting press is
addicting and I've fallen into the Trap
before of like oh this is addicting I
want to keep going but then I realized a
day later I'm like slow your roll like
this is not okay
and I think that that might be the
situation they're in or they might just
be young and reality TV stars and yeah
messing up you know he's only 40. you're
right you've got to give him but you've
got to give him a break his life's on
display and like
yes yes he messed up and he admits to
messing up I mean he on his forces
Master interview said I want to take a
beating I want to be punished and he
knows that what he did was wrong but now
I mean the whole world is making him pay
for it on the daily you know I think
like you know TV and public life is
bizarre
[Music]